[Applause]
and finally new rule with two senate
seats in georgia still possible
seats that will make the difference
between gridlock and progress
democrats must figure out why so many
voters still say to them
you're good enough you're smart enough
but doug on it we don't like you
under the headline something went wrong
the new york times described a
post-election conference call between
democratic leaders where they
wept cursed and traded blame
wait i thought we won this one
which we did we did and yes ding dong
the whiny little [ __ ] is dead
celebration is in order we took a big
step toward saving democracy and in the
process
lost 280 pounds of ugly fat all right
that's my last fat joke
about trump for the next five minutes
but democrats were supposed to flip the
senate and didn't
supposed to flip state legislatures not
a one
and they lost seats in the house in a
year that was so much about making
people aware of racism
their share of minority votes went down
the message to democrats from so much of
the country seems to be we don't like
trump but we still can't bring ourselves
to vote for you
if crackerjack was made of popcorn and
dog
[ __ ] and half the people threw out the
popcorn
popcorn should want to know why
liberals can either write off half the
country
as irredeemable or they can ask what is
it about a d
next to a candidate's name that makes it
so toxic
let's ask ruben gallego he's a
congressman from arizona and he was
asked how his democrats could do a
better job connecting to latinos
he said first start by not using the
term latinx
which the vast majority of latinos have
never heard of and when they do
don't like it who likes it pandering
white
politicians who mistake twitter for real
people
and don't get it that latinx is like
fetch
you can try to make it happen but it's
never gonna
virginia congresswoman abigail
spanberger said after the election if we
are classifying tuesday as a success we
will get
[ __ ] torn apart in 2022. that's a
congresswoman
she was urging members not to talk about
defunding the police
james clyburn agreed defund the police
is killing our party
he said pennsylvania democrat conor lamb
says democratic rhetoric
needs to be dialed back it needs to be
rooted in common sense
thank you thank you
there in my opinion is the crux of the
problem democrats too often don't come
across
as having common sense to a huge swath
of americans
and these are people who believe in cuba
but as i've said before politics in this
country is binary you have to wear
everything anyone on your side does
republicans are the party of
don't wear masks kids in cages lock her
up
and democrats are the party of
every hypersensitive social justice
warrior
woke [ __ ] story in the news
they're the party that disappears people
or tries to make them apologize for
ridiculous
things anne hathaway
apologized last week because in her new
movie she plays a witch
a fictional character that has three
claw-like fingers and that's offensive
to
people with limb differences
the week before the nhl's arizona
coyotes dropped a player after it came
out in the press that when he was in
eighth grade he bullied a disabled kid
yes that's a bad thing to do but are we
really going after people for what they
did in
middle school now democrats already lost
seats for going after what brett
kavanaugh did in high school
common sense last year i read about how
nbc
held an emergency meeting to determine
if mario lopez should be fired from his
job at access hollywood
i thought holy [ __ ] did he sexually
assault somebody
no he went on a podcast and when the
host brought up the trend of liberal
parents letting toddlers pick their
gender identity
he said my god if you're three years old
and you're saying
you think you're a boy or a girl i just
think it's a dangerous
as a parent to make that determination
cue the groveling apology followed by
america saying uh yeah i think mario's
right
maybe kids shouldn't make big life
decisions while you still need to make
choo choo noises to get the food in
their mouth
i can do this all day cite stories
big and small that are endlessly on
people's news feeds
that add up to a constant drip drip drip
of
these people are nuts everybody heard
about that story out of san francisco
about a guy who got on a crowded
elevator with a female professor
and when she asked what floor he said
women's lingerie
you know a little joke for which he
earned a formal complaint because it
left her
shaken shaken who are these jellyfish
like the woman who almost derailed
biden's campaign because he kissed the
back of her head
before she went out to make a speech she
said her brain couldn't process what was
happening
really your brain couldn't process that
like string theory or
wormholes
an old man was trying to show support in
his old man way
she said she was embarrassed shocked
confused well then the outside world
isn't for you
[Music]
and certainly running the world isn't
i talked to a guy in the midwest once
who told me this story about the day he
went out to get his car in the
supermarket parking lot but
couldn't back out because a mother and
her very young daughter were standing
behind his car
which was next to their car which had a
hillary bumper sticker on it
and the little girl was screaming at her
mother who was profusely apologizing to
the child
and he said to me i just can't let
people like that take over this country
that's what people vote on not policy
democrats kept saying in the campaign
you can't possibly think trump
is preferable to what we're selling and
many voters keep saying
yes we can
in fact our primary reason voting for
him is to create a bulwark against
you because your side thinks silence is
violence and looting is not
because you're the party of chasing
speakers off college campuses
and making everyone walk on eggshells
and replacing
let's not see color with let's see it
always and everywhere
formally the position of the ku klux
klan
it would be so easy to win elections if
we would just drop this [ __ ]
democrats need to listen to our new
president-elect's
old boss this idea of purity and you're
never compromised and you're always
politically
woke and all that stuff you should get
over that quickly
quickly like before they vote in georgia
you